so stability has some value but it
doesn't mean that everybody's happy in
fact it just means that nobody can find
anybody else who's equally unhappy that
they would want to run off with so let's
examine the question of how well people
do using the mating ritual or in other
possible ways of finding stable
marriages so basically we want to begin
with the question of who does better the
boys of the girls maybe it's a mixture
maybe the boys do better the girls do
better or maybe some boys do better than
others and some girls do better than
others and one thing to notice is we
know that the girls suitors are getting
better day by day and that sounds like
you know the mating ritual might be
slanted towards them likewise the boys
sweethearts the ones that they're
serenading are getting worse day by day
and that sounds like it might be an
argument for the girls to do better but
that's not true and the reason it's not
is that if you think about it the boys
are starting off with their first choice
they begin by serenading the girl at the
top of their list and it's true the day
by day they keep going down or staying
the same or going down but they're only
sinking - in fact the best possible
woman that they can be married to let's
examine that so I need a definition
which is that we'll say that a woman
Cole is called optimal for Keith when
she is the highest ranked girl he can
stay bleem Airi so let's think about
that from it so Keith has his preference
for different girls that he likes for
two different degrees and if it maybe
some that he likes like Keith thinks
that angelina is terrific but there's
just no way that that she's gonna wind
up with him because she just ranks him
very lowly so there's no stable set of
marriages in which Keith can wind up
with this very desirable woman Angelina
but if you look at all of the sets of
marriages that you know that are stable
that Keith can be involved in among them
Nicole is the woman that he most likes
so that's what we mean by
coal is optimal for case she's optimal
among the feasible women that he could
stately be married to and the claim that
we're making is that the mating ritual
yields a set of stable marriages which
is simultaneously optimal for Keith and
all the other boys at once now that's a
kind of unusual thing you usually when
you're optimizing you figure you're
optimized for one boy and it sacrifices
the optimality for the other boys but
that's not what happens in the mating
ritual all of the boys get their
absolutely optimal spouse in the mating
ritual and dooli it turns out that all
of the girls get the worst possible
spouse that they can get a pessimal
spouse among all possible stable
marriages okay well with that claim
understood let's go about proving it and
we're going to prove that the mating
ritual leads to boy optimal marriages by
contradiction so let's suppose that
Nicole is optimal for Keith among all
the women that Keith could possibly be
married to in a stable way Nicole is the
best suppose that Keith does not wind up
marrying Nicole in some in the mating
ritual okay so he doesn't marry Nicole
in the mating ritual that means that he
must have since Nicole is is optimal for
Keith he must be married to somebody
that's less desirable to him than Nicole
so he must have crossed Nicole off on
some day let's call that his bad day so
on his bad day Keith is rejected by his
optimal spouse okay among well if this
ever happens there's gonna be some boy
for which who has the earliest bad day
we may as well assume that it's Keith so
let's assume that keith was the earliest
among the boys to have a bad day that is
a day on which he crosses off his
optimal spouse because he was rejected
by her well on this bad day when Keith
crosses off Nicole it's because Nicole
rejected him which meant that Nicole had
a suitor that she liked better
than Keith let's call that suitor Tom so
what we know is that Nicole prefers this
guy Tom to Keith on the day that she
that she that she rejected Keith and he
crossed her off and we also know since
this is the earliest bad day that
anybody has um Tom has not yet crossed
off his optimal girl so what that means
is that since he's serenading Nicole and
she's gonna wind up rejecting Keith in
favor of Tom it must be the case that
well Nicole is at least as desirable to
Tom as his optimal spouse because he
hasn't gotten to his optimal spouse yet
he's working his way down the list and
he hasn't had a bad day yet so let's put
these two pieces together
Nicole is at least as desirable to Tom
as Tom's optimal spouse and Nicole
prefers Tom to Keith well what that
tells us is that if I had a set of
stable marriages with Nicole married to
Keith then in the stable set of
marriages of course tom is gonna be
married to somebody that's at best
optimal for him so he's married to
somebody that he likes uh less than the
Cole and Nicole is married to Keith and
she likes Tom better than who she's
married to
what that tells us is that Nicole and
Tom are a rogue couple in any stable set
of marriages where Nicole is married to
Keith but that contradicts the fact that
Nicole's supposed to be optimal for
Keith they're supposed to be a stable
set of marriages where Nicole is married
to Keith so a similar argument it's
actually slightly easier is that the
mating ritual yields a set of stable
marriages in which all of the girls get
the worst possible spouse that they can
have in any set of stable marriages okay
so this leads to a whole bunch of
questions and it turns out that there's
a very rich theory of stable marriages
as I mentioned the first question to ask
is well are there other paths
both stable marriages well one thing you
can obviously do is you could switch the
roles of the boys and the girls so if
you switch the roles in the boys and the
girls you'll get a set of stable
marriages that are optimal
for the girls and pessimal for the boys
maybe that's fair fair you'd rather do
that so that's at least a possibility of
using the mating ritual to get to
different stable sets of marriages
unless the two happen to be the same and
a question arises are there others that
could exist that the mating ritual
doesn't find either by choosing the boys
to act as boys or the boys to act as
girls and the answer is that in general
there can be many as a matter of fact if
there are n boys and girls it's possible
that there could be an exponential
number of stable marriages in N and that
leads to the question of well which is
one that might be a better one to choose
compared to the one that completely
favors the boys or completely favors the
girls another interesting question that
comes up that's a an issue that comes up
with general protocols of negotiation
and optimization among multiple parties
is does it serve anybody to lie that is
instead of following the protocol and
always going to thee and the boys always
serenading the girls that they like best
and the girls always rejecting anybody
that's less desirable than their
favorite suitor suppose they violate the
convention and lie can they do better
well it turns out that of course the
boys in the mating ritual are doing
optimal so they don't gain anything by
trying to lie but the girls it turns out
of almost it's almost the case that
girls can do better by lying if they
could if they conspire together to lie
they can actually force the mating
ritual to wind up turning into a stable
set of marriages that's girl optimal so
that raises another issue about are
there protocols which are resistant to
lying we're not going to go into these
questions we mainly want it to
understand the stable marriage problem
which and its application
and how to find him again if you want to
learn more about this you can look at
the book by Gus field and Irving that I
mentioned in a previous video